[Musique]
à jouy-le-moutier l'atelier de patrick
macarez c'est un peu un dispensaire pour
accordéon et comme les médecins ils se
font rares en france
alors depuis qu'il s'est installé en
2012 patrick demont pack travail d'aller
soucis avec ton instrument lui c'est
arnaud méthivier il a joué avec georges
moustaki francis cabrel susan vega ou
encore matthieu chedid à vouloir un
facteur d'accordéon près de chez soi
c'est le must pour ce compositeur car
avant il lui arrivait de prendre l'avion
pour faire réparer son instrument
patrick comprend la musique que je fais
et ça c'est un avantage pour réparer
d'une certaine façon l'instrument l'ag
de ses droits
un service premium de réparation
singulière qui correspondent à la
musique des pièces qui a disparu
[Musique]
quand les artistes sont dans la boutique
moi je travaille essayer les instruments
qui sont dans la boutique parce qu'il ya
toujours des nouveautés et des
curiosités pour eux et moi j'ai les
crocs j'ai des concerts gratuits passé
c'est agréable on peut le faire métal le
bois - les soufflets quand on peut plus
le réparer on les change comme les
outils existent pas vraiment mon
commerce
et bien lors de la formation on a appris
à fabriquer certains outils donc les
gens à se fabriquer des outils parfois
qui est un outil qui va servir une seule
fois juste pour une réparation ainsi
pour l'utilisera pu donc le principe de
l'accordage limay sur le haut de la dame
ça la conséquence aux montants fréquence
donc on est note qui sera un peu plus
aiguë et avec un autre outil on va
pouvoir gratter sur le bas de la lame
est la conséquence on abaisse la
fréquence et on est notes les plus
graves mais l'oreille de l'accordeur
c'est pas la même oreille que celle du
musicien
pour accorder principalement on va voir
on cherche toujours les d'une race son
savoir-faire patrick l'a appris sur le
tard il avait 50 ans quand il est
retourné sur les bancs de l'école mais
ses oreilles elle était déjà acquise à
l'instrument car son premier accordéon
patrick la tenue entre ses mains à l'âge
de 8 ans premier prix de conservatoire
de valenciennes et l'a enseigné
plusieurs années avant de se tourner
vers les métiers de l'immobilier
[Musique]
j'ai abandonnée pendant quasiment 25 ans
et plus et 8 cette envie de retour vers
l'anzhi est du coup la formation de
luthier de facteurs d'accordéon m'a
donné cette opportunité de revenir vers
la musique d'une autre manière mais je
suis vraiment ravi d'avoir fait quoi
c'est cetc
ils ne sont qu'une cinquantaine comme
patrick a exercé le métier de facteur
d'accordéon en france quand l'instrument
suscite toujours autant d'intérêt dans
les milieux du jazz du rock et surtout
auprès des enfants
[Musique]
à